what's the difference between say
streaming in a big studio film you
specifically chose to do this and turn
down so much money yeah to do it on
streaming I mean one I love Netflix
don't get me wrong yeah I watch it all
the time it's constantly on please don't
revoke my subscription but I do think
for this movie for this particular set
of circumstances we knew the power of
cinema we have not given up on the power
of movies I know for a fact we would not
be getting this fervor we would not be
in the conversation as much as we are if
we were on a streaming service plus the
stream of service is way ahead of the
studio system the streams are already
doing this stuff they are a cutting edge
to get to the eyeballs right away the
movie business is the one that is
old-fashioned that has not break in that
mold yet and we knew we were in a
position we didn't need the money we
didn't we had an agenda to get this to
the most eyeballs but but at a place
that it could affect the most people and
so having us big studio big
conglomerates say this is worth tens of
millions of dollars to throw down for
marketing and this is worth your time to
leave your house and fight parking and
sit in a dark room and watch this movie
again spreads to all the different
mediums and says something bigger than
just this is a piece of content a story
go check it out this is an event to move
your life gather your friends and
appreciate the world that we live in